hey everybody is Jessie and today I'm
going to attempt something that I
haven't done before and I'm not exactly
sure how I'm going to do it and I'm
excited about it I don't know about you
but I get excited when I'm going to do
something that's going to be cool and
useful to the user and especially when
I'm not really sure how I'm going to do
it because I know I'm going to learn
something and it's going to be awesome
when it comes together and happens so
let me show you I'm kind of right in the
middle of kind of taking this stuff and
making it its own component and I was
going to put it in the utils falter and
because I'm going to use this in
multiple pages now so it'd probably be
better if it was separated out so that's
in anticipation for what we're about to
do and let me bring bring a window over
so you can see so I did make oh that's
not good I made the search function live
so for now this is the alignment of the
search if you watch the this show when
we set this up there was a lot of debate
over how we should align this so I'm
expecting another input to be here in
the near future we'll see how it goes if
we do end up not putting something here
then maybe this will change but for now
it's right here and it works and we also
added the the images or live they don't
show up all the time when I'm doing
local development but on catechetical
calm the images show up at least one
image there's only one image that's been
uploaded that's big enough to actually
be used the rest of them the width gets
checked and it doesn't use them if
they're not wide enough so we're going
to work on today
if my alright I'll just show you over
here
for some reason it's not reloading
but the live site will be fine so what I
want to do on the events page down at
the bottom right now I have this
responsive table right so it works even
on small screens because you know you're
you get to scroll horizontally and
obviously even when it gets smaller you
know still works not ideal if you're on
a screen this small but but it's
definitely more usable than a normal
table would be it which would throw off
everything and we'd have horizontal
scrolling of the entire page so what I
want to be able to do all these are
pulled in from the WordPress API so what
I think I should do it might be the
easiest is I want these to be sortable
so if you click date you can get it from
right now it shows the events let's see
so the events that are coming up the
soonest or at first so that's by default
how everything's sorted which makes
sense people probably want to know
what's coming up soonest but there's a
lot of other things you could sort by
year so potentially you someone might
want to sort by any of these things with
the exception of link obviously probably
the emails don't need to be sorted by
but I could see definitely these might
want to sort by these although kind of
stinks everybody has doctor and from
their name because it's not is everybody
if everyone's a doctor maybe it'll work
out but now I say so it is going to kind
of mess up the alphabetical sorting here
but since people have doctor but other
than that you can see my point it would
be nice to be able to sort this either
you know alphabetic order reverse
alphabetic order maybe reverse it so we
see the events that are coming up the
latest first I think location will
probably be the most useful
you know maybe somebody's not interested
in traveling for so they don't care
events not near them so maybe they want
to you know sorted by that the other
thing I'd like to do if I have time is
have a search bar for for this so just
like we had on the resources page they
could search I'm not sure where I would
put the search bar in this setup here
would be it would be a little bit more
awkward awkward looking I think to fit
it in here so I have to give some
thought to that but I can at least get
the the functionality down and then
worry later on about how I'm going to
style that but that the search function
could be super useful because you could
potentially just put in the name of your
city or a city near you and then get
that or the name of a speaker but you
really like and then they would just
Auto populate just like the resources so
at first I thought I would just take
whatever data automatically got pulled
in you know on the initial page live
from the WordPress API and then just
manipulate that data to sort it
differently but then I thought maybe it
would be better to actually make another
API call when we do a sort and I'm not
I'm not 100% decided on this but my
reasoning being you the limit on how
many how many events I can get from an
API call is 100 so there may be some way
around that limit but that's that's the
limit I've hit with the WordPress API
limits you 200 which is fine you know
you don't want to pull in a ton of data
but the you know for something like this
it's not really a lot it's just some
text you know JSON so I had thought well
if somebody you know if they really
wanted to get a more accurate listing
you know let's say they want to go in
reverse alphabetical order well they
want to see everything from these
speakers so I don't I don't know not not
just whatever the you
the first 100 that came up let's say
there's 500 events in here I don't think
they'll ever be that many but if there
were 500 they'd be missing out on most
of the events so anyway think about that
let me know what you think on what would
a user expect from sorting this or is
there a totally different way or would
just the search bar be sufficient and I
shouldn't even worry about necessarily
about the sorting as much all right I'm
going to go and say hi to everybody in
the live set I just wanted to get
everything out of the way for people
that are joining maybe for the first
time just kind of let them know what's
going on if you are joining joining for
the first time this is just me streaming
projects that I'm working on for my
everyday job so it's not necessarily a
tutorial some sometimes it kind of feels
more like a tutorial but a lot of times
it's me just trying to figure out how to
do things and everybody watching helping
out with that so if you're interested in
that stick around if not thanks for
joining in and maybe join a different
time alright so let me look it looks
like everybody's just saying hi hey
everyone oh there's spoilers it says hit
hits hearth I'm not sure if that's how
you pronounce the name sorry if I
mispronounced it hits heart says want
spoilers something new is coming to FCC
free code camp I'm I'm interested in
that I don't know is anybody else
interested I don't know what's what
spoilers it would be but I'd be excited
about something new Andy asks what's
going on hopefully you just heard my
explanation it looks like you you asked
that before I explain this hopefully got
that also
so Andy M is in the live chat he also
does a live stream so I don't I haven't
really talked to Andy about it but I did
check out a little bit I only had a few
minutes the other day but I
I thought I want to check out some of
the live streams so I didn't watch a lot
but I did check it out so if you want
more live streaming check out Andy's
channel on YouTube all right so we got
one question in in the latch at says
what data are you pulling at the moment
a limited number of events by date yeah
so right now the data that I'm pulling
is a 100 100 events now what I did I I
think I may have made this so that it
doesn't show previous events let's take
a minute and look at what the code I did
this a few weeks ago so I actually can't
remember I know I had intended to make
it like that but I can't remember if I
did so let's go into events I'm going to
come back to this in a minute but let's
go to events and see okay so I'm
filtering by date order by ending so
look down where I'm actually using it
maybe I have oh now I remember I did end
up
ended up doing something
maybe I didn't maybe I'm not seeing it
here if you all see this when you can
check out the the github repo it's it's
all updated at this point and you can
check this out as well the links in the
description I also have links to what we
worked on yesterday which was setting up
prettier and standard J s which by the
way is really amazing I'm really liking
using that so then they submitted that
pull request to set all that up and I
really appreciate that because every
time I use it I'm just I just love it
even more so let me just explain since I
can't find in the code whether or not I
actually did this here's what my
intention was
I have I'm obviously pulling a date here
so I have two different dates that I'm
pulling one is the displayed date so
that's what you see here so this is the
format that it was requested that the
day be put in so that's that's how it
shows up and that's just a text field
that whoever's managing that content
puts in there they can put whatever they
wanted to but that's not really easy to
sort by right so I needed a better
format for the date so then I also added
a field that would give me the date in a
format that was easier to use so I have
that format as well and I'm not doing
anything with it yet it looks like at
least here but my intention was to only
show events that were going to happen so
any events that had already happened
they wouldn't show up anymore now I
guess it wouldn't be ideal to do it here
and assorted here because that would be
a waste of your data being sent so the
ideal place to do it would be actually
so I froze scrolling around here it
would be actually here where I make the
call
so they give these parameters for what
date I want and then that way I wouldn't
even waste time even
grabbing data that I know I'm not going
to use so filter by date but I don't
think I'm yeah I'm not doing it there
I'm not sure how how I do it so I have
it set up so that it could be done in
terms of the data coming through and
I'll show you what it looks like
let's grab we'll take a look at this the
raw data that might be a good place to
start and then we'll all be on the same
page in terms of what data were actually
getting and you know how we can
manipulate that to do what we want it
sounds bad when I say I'm going to
manipulate the data like like I'm doing
something wrong to it but I'm not I'm
just just going to add it into the site
event
all right so here's the data that I'm
getting we have a title we have so
here's the day this is what I was
talking about and it's easier just to
show you so we have two dates
there's the display date and then we
have the actual date and it comes in
this just in this format which is it's a
nice easy format and that you know it's
I can just sort on the date varies I
don't even have to convert this or
anything like that which if you've
worked with dates in JavaScript it's not
always the most pleasant thing to do but
I don't even have to worry about that
it's just one number the higher the
number means the later the date so what
do you think I'm going to go to before I
do this I make a decision on this I want
to go to a live stream I'm going to see
if I've got responses to any of the I
think I've had several questions over
the last couple minutes so I don't want
to get too far ahead of myself I may
have had some really good ideas and a
come through the live chat Oscar says hi
from Colombia hey how's it going thanks
for watching
Dennis s is that Dennis or didn't he
sorry if I'm mispronouncing that a DN is
what what do you think about async/await
promises I'm actually using a weight
like async/await stuff here I don't
think I'm as I'm knowledgeable enough
about async/await and promises to give a
really good answer I will say the few
times that I've used them I've really
liked using them basically it's always
in the concept context of using fetch
that I end up using async/await and
promises and stuff so I like it but I
don't know enough about it to give you
any detailed explanation of it but it's
definitely easier than like having lots
of callbacks and things like that
umberto says I'm always working using
database back and then still don't have
much information about WordPress API but
maybe a drop-down for each row to filter
on dates the filter would be a date
range names would be a list to pick from
event titles and locations ha it's just
possibly too much functionality for a
small feature I hadn't thought about
before let me think about that for a
second so let me bring this over so you
just get the visual so we're thinking
there would be a drop-down for each row
and then in that drop-down they could
select something either a date range or
something else in this rows to filter by
hmm that that could work that could
definitely work
I could populate the dropdowns based on
the data that I get from the API so
everything that was in here could be in
the drop-down I could do a check and if
it if it equals something that was
already in the drop-down it wouldn't put
it in twice that could way that would it
would be you're right it would be a lot
of work it might be overkill for this
feature but I think in terms of the
layout of the site this is kind of
tucked away now you know it's at the
bottom of this page which I realize this
this is the main event that's being put
on by this cata catechol Institute so in
terms of conferences this is this and
this are their main conferences so this
is more of a collaboration I think with
another department here but you know
this is their main conference so they do
want to highlight that but really for
from a user's perspective this is
probably going to be one of the most
useful parts of the site I would say
this and the resource section that we've
been working on for the last week or so
so it might warrant a little bit more
work
I don't know let me know let me know
what you all think about that or would
it you know we could potentially do
something similar just with a search bar
that OTO suggests things and we can
populate the autosuggest
from these values as well would that be
cleaner I'm a little worried about the
clutter of dropdowns all right let's um
actually do I want to get into some code
so there's definitely some stuff that we
can do without making these decisions
yet so I want to get in there and do
some of that stuff to prepare and then
that way we'll get some things done and
you will get to see some coding since I
claim to be live coding and so far I've
just been live talking so we'll do some
of that first and then we'll come back
and make some decisions on how exactly
we want you know visually this to look
and for people to be able to search but
I mean I think it's pretty much agreed
at least in my mind that somehow there I
want users to be able to filter these
ice or sort them in some way to find
what they want and more easily than
having to actually scroll right now
there's not that many but eventually it
could be really difficult to find what
you want and not a good user experience
alright so here's what I was thinking we
need to set up so I have I know this is
a little bit smaller than normal and
that's on purpose because I have had
these side-by-side and I needed to see
what was going on so I will zoom in in
just just a few seconds here but I have
resources on this side because resources
is not going to be the model for how we
do everything else because we had a lot
of refactoring going on here and some
pool requests related to this so this is
kind of the most polished way to do
things we're doing thing we're not using
jQuery for everything here we're doing
it you know more more of the react way
I just noticed I had my phone right next
to the mic so I apologize if there are
any like static sounds I'm going to move
it farther away now let me know if you
hear static and I'll move it like to the
other side of the room if I have to so
anyway this is going to be the model so
I've already started to bring over some
of that into here so I will kind of move
this over make this text bigger so we
can all see so instead of just saving
this data to props and being done with
it now we're going to go we're going to
set the state and we are initially going
to take this data that's that's a props
and we're going to use it to set the
state and then we're going to down here
man I can't wait until I get all this
pulled in through the API so don't have
to scroll through it but instead of
props here it's going to be state so I
can actually let's change this to state
I think I have enough code near for this
to work at this point change it to state
and my dev server should be yeah it's
working now so we can see you on
localhost
it did work alright so now we're
grabbing from state the reason that
that's important if you didn't see what
we did with the resources if you didn't
happen to see that that show that's
important because now every time we
change state all of these will
automatically change and that's that's
the react more of the react way to
manipulate the Dom is through changing
state and not as we were doing on some
pages using jQuery
all right so so that's that's done so
that's basically converted to set us up
so that however we want to sort this all
we have to do is change change the way
things are in state and then all that
will fall into place we want to we want
to add this so assuming we're going to
make some API calls after get initial
props I wanted to add this section here
which we use for our API calls whenever
we're doing our live search in the
section for resources I want to extract
this out and make it its own component
so I've already extracted some of this
out I'm importing isomorphic fetch now I
realized when we when I first talked
about this I was saying something about
I don't know if this will work because I
don't know about how it how it uses
basically polyfills for fetch and
everything I didn't know if this
isomorphic fetch only worked in the
server side but then when I was doing
this again I thought that was actually
kind of ridiculous and didn't make sense
what I was saying before because
obviously whatever is going on here with
fetch works on the client side and the
server side you know this works all of
you otherwise our client-side routing
would not work so that definitely works
so I figured maybe I ought to import
isomorphic fetch because maybe maybe I
don't know this yet I could have tested
it that's what's necessary to make fetch
work either way on client side or server
side so I did import that if you have
any insight to know whether or not I
need to import it here just let me know
but I can always take it out but for now
I'm going to import it so everything's
set up here I think it's all set up I
need to pass a URL yeah I'm passing the
URL in here to get I need to pass
kid you all yeah I need to pass the URL
n as well here and I did have a question
about the syntax I don't know why so
when I'm using an arrow function here I
don't I'm assuming here I don't need to
put the parentheses around it right is
that is that a correct assumption since
I didn't do it here and it's working I
know there's a delay in the live stream
so I'm not going to get an answer right
away but I'm going to go back to the
live chat since now we've come a little
bit further I want to make sure they
lose anybody or I didn't miss a good
suggestion and if you have any questions
feel free to put it in the live chat
I got keep calling the live chat live
stream sorry about that
put it in the live chat or if you can't
stick around and wait for the answer put
it in the comments the video or direct
message me on Twitter I know if you I
say that all the time if you've been
watching but I'm mainly saying it for
people who might be new and watching for
the first time
alright so okay so this is a
continuation of the the question about
async await promises since I saw you use
promises and get JSON function but don't
use async await there okay yeah actually
that is a good question basically um the
reason I didn't do that is because and
this is going to be a this is going to
make me sound like a noob but I'm
obviously if you've watched any of my
other episodes you know I'm not afraid
to look like a noob this is how it was
done in the documentation for next it
had all this kind of pre-made so this
has been adapted slightly to my needs
but I this was from there so I didn't
mess with it and I used it
this I grabbed from a previous project
and I knew it worked so I grabbed it and
I didn't really modify it too much the
only thing I modified was I use arrow
functions so that when I use this inside
of here it would be the right this which
now what I'm extracting this out I'm not
even sure if I'll have the right this
anymore but we can test it and find out
so the answer is I just hadn't even
thought of that
I hadn't thought of why I would use it
one way or another I just knew that they
worked and so I kept them like that and
didn't really mess with them too much so
that's that's the honest reason it's not
a grant a really good reason or reason
that makes me look good but that's
really why I didn't use a sink or a wait
there if someone else has more knowledge
about when to use async/await and when
to not use it please uh you know put
that in the live chat because I'd like
to know more about it as well I think
that's how it is sometimes I don't know
if it's like that for all of you but for
me certainly sometimes you get you grab
some code you know it works you know
enough about it to modify to your needs
but you still don't completely know why
it works I mean I think that's it I mean
don't think about I really everybody
does that I think about all the packages
that projects load from you know the
node modules and stuff you know I don't
know of anybody that knows what
everything does and why it does what it
does but we all still use it so that's
what's going on there basically is I
know it works I'm not exactly sure why
it needs to be like that
all right so Andres and what do you have
to sort so maybe on maybe engines
getting in a little a basically we're
sorting this so we're going to sort by
date would be useful to sort by and look
date and location are going to be the
most useful things to sort by presenter
maybe but I could see presenter being
more like something you would want to
search for especially because we have
doctor in front of a lot of names so
that just messes up our alphabetical
order right now I could maybe try to ask
the person that's inputting all this
data and WordPress to maybe put a comma
and then doctor so we could but even so
like we still have first names ideally
we would have last name comma first name
comma and then title but that wouldn't
really look that nice so that might end
up just being something that's
searchable so in any case we want
alphabetical order for this and then we
want to order by date for this and
possibly alphabetical order for this as
well
um dr. Pavel says hi Jesse as the title
says find the nearby event may be better
made search bar for an exact request and
just button something like show nearest
event use geolocation that's a great
idea that was my initial idea when when
the people I was making the site for
requested this section it said find a
nearby event I immediately thought geo
location but that's not what they had in
mind so this is one of the areas where I
kind of delivered pretty much exactly
what the specifications were but I had
intended if I had time to do more than
then what will say the client in this
case but really they work at the same
organization that I do so yeah I agree
it makes if you're going to call the
section find a nearby event you would
expect some sort of geolocation or at
least some place where you could
manually type in your address or
something like that so that's I'm not
going to work on that today because you
know if people came based on the title
of what this is going to be which is
being able to sort a table data in a
table and react and I'd rather work on
that now and then save the geolocation
thing for another you know maybe
tomorrow but I think that's an awesome
idea
let's see
at a question about from I know if it's
Michael or Michal I'm not sure how you
pronounce the reason of doing of going
with fetch as opposed to library like
Axios Patrick gave a nice answer to that
fetches a new shine this is Patrick
tensor fetches a new shiny way to make
things simple simple is the reason those
libraries came about fetch is built into
updated browsers so yeah yeah that's a
great answer Patrick yeah fetch fetch is
like is now the newer browsers its
built-in so like it's it's more
lightweight you don't have to add an
extra library to do the same thing you
just do it with fetch and it's easy I
mean obviously you can see from you know
from how it is here it's it's super
short it's really easy way easier than
trying to do with jQuery or even just
straight xhr so that's that's why I use
it and with the polyfill older browsers
are fine too so you can pretty much use
it for most projects yeah Patrick says I
think isomorphic means work on the
client and server in this context yeah
Patrick's a single argument doesn't need
parenthesis good to know
all right so Andrew linked a design for
it looks like better data tables so
maybe I'll take a look at that
I don't know Andrew do you want me to
take a look at that now or should I just
check that out later so anyway I'm going
to this should work then assuming that
I'm doing the correct thing when it
comes to this then this should work so
let's go ahead and save this and Wow
where am I at
projects I'm going to save this in Utah
so should we just call this if I just
call it fetch do I wanna yeah I'm gonna
go with I was just checking to see
whether or not the other component in
here was uppercase or lowercase so it is
already lowercase so I'll just go with
that
this was called fetch j/s whoa
that was weird if you didn't see that
Texas said the editor is not responding
so that would have been bad ooh oh
excuse me sorry to sneeze um that would
have been bad if my editor crashed right
in the middle of this uh okay so what am
I getting all these yeah I haven't I'm
going to get weird stuff happening with
uh with my editor as far as the hints go
because I haven't updated my packages to
reflect the stuff that we're doing here
I'm poor this motion fish I'm definitely
going to get rid of all these soon
alright so I'm going to save that and
now we need to to test to test this I'm
going to edit this resources file and
we're going to import what do we need to
import we're going to call
so I'm just trying to remember which one
I call first we're going to call get
JSON and then that's going to call get
so what I want to grab from there is I'm
just going to copy this since we're
going to use the same basic format here
what I want to get is the function get
JSON from fetch okay and we don't have
to put the Dodge as obviously you can
see here and that should be enough that
should work
so I'm going to save that and I'm going
to bring over resources let's see we
should now if I search this should work
so let's go nice it does work great all
right so now actually I'm not even going
to look at what's in the live chat right
now because I know somebody noticed this
and it's trying to call me out I should
have removed all that to make sure that
it really was working so now I am
removing it I'm gonna do a empty cache
and refresh just to be sure that I'm
getting rid all that now let's try it
okay now it's not working so um
[Music]
oh thanks because you're saying bless
you from when I sneeze thanks guys
so we have a come from J Steve Martinez
says fetch has no support on ie that's
true yeah there's no support so you want
to use a polyfill it's depending on what
you need to support if you use older
browsers use the polyfill for fetch to
have it work in older browsers so I have
used fetch before with the polyfill and
gotten it to work in IE 11 I didn't
tested any farther back than 11 but it
does work alright so I'm going to check
out Andrews saying that this link he
sent is a good example of design for a
table so let's check it out
oops maybe
I'm not getting I got a 404 when I tried
to type that in what did I mess up yeah
I'm getting a 404 till Andrew I don't
know I tried to type in that link and
it's not working for me
yeah that's what I did Andrew saying
changed the star with dot that's what I
did I replace the I did replace the star
with a dot and whoa what did it still
four or four yeah okay so Sebastian is
getting to four or four as well so it's
not just that's just me I thought I was
doing something wrong
all right so let's troubleshoot and see
let's see what's going on I guess it's
not like I don't have to get this
working right now so really we can skip
this and just work on it later and then
just get onto some more like the sorting
stuff so I can throw this back in here
and get rid of this for now and work on
this later and let's just throw these in
here oops
thought I copied these I guess not
there we go so we'll just throw those in
there for now obviously it would be
better to have these separately so we
don't repeat ourselves and multiple
multiple pages but for now this should
work so what we need to do for now let's
just have let's do a reverse date so
let's see if we can reverse the date few
because that should be the easiest thing
to do we're going to have let's find
it's fine where you have the date let me
let me describe to you what's going to
happen here so we can go through the
steps to make sure this makes sense
logically so what I'm going to do is on
the date I'll bring it over here so we
can all see it so where it says date
here we're going to have an on click
event handler there so on click it's
going to fire off a call an API call
that is going to grab this data and it's
going to basically use the same URL
except it's going to order by descending
instead of ascending all right that's
what I'm starting with this one is going
to be so easy to to do at that point
it's the state is going to get reset
with this data that's now sorted in a
different way and then that's going to
change change the order of these does
that make sense to everyone
all right so we're just going to make a
function I'm going to make the function
first before I even before I do the
click the on click because that's not
really a big deal so I'm going to make
the function and all we really need is
when we do this is to grab we just need
to make a call an API call so I'm
actually going to grab a lot of what we
did over here just so we don't have to
type it out again because it'll be very
similar
so this is already doing a lot of what
we want to do here we'll just have to
change the parameters in for the API
call all right so basically we're
getting near this is the URL and these
are the parameters which we're now going
to change to this
and we're going to change this to
descending so we're going to change the
order and then so we're making the API
call it's going why did I split this in
between I don't want to split those up
okay so we're making the call here and
then that's going to use fetch within
here it's going to return us JSON just
great and then we're going to take that
data that JSON data and we're now going
to make that this state we're going to
set that to data in the state once the
state is set then that will trigger all
the components you know to re-render
down here so I'm going to save that and
now what did I call this we call it a
sort date okay so let's go down and find
where we actually have the word date
here we go so let's go on on click and
then this is how we do we just call it
this is how we called it
um which the Patrick says why are you
not importing get JSON and events dot J
s I'm not sure I know perhaps Patrick
saying dry man dry yeah so I want to do
it like that
but when I tried it I don't know if I
maybe I did it on my other screen and so
you all didn't see it but when I so I
put this in this separate file here and
I tried to import it in resources as a
test and it didn't work
I don't maybe I didn't say that out loud
and just thought it sorry about that so
it didn't work so instead of spending
time trying to fix this right now I
wanted to get more like to the point of
the topic I don't want to be false
advertiser here since since I made the
title the video about sorting a table
and I tweeted saying that I was going to
try to sort a table I wanted to get to
that if we get this down
I almost said if we get this sorted but
that would have been just trying to be
funny but um if we get this down then I
can go back and try to get this so
Patrick I totally I totally agree with
you and I want to do that so it's gonna
happen but I just wanted to get
something accomplished and not not spend
my time on something that I didn't
absolutely need to be to be working
right right here so this should work
right I know we had a vaguely remember
that having some sort of trouble with
whether or not what was I doing whether
or not I call the function on and where
did I do this
come on click oh I guess I'll see it in
a second
okay so right now let me pull this over
right now nothing happened when I click
that so do I need to call this oh this
always have to put this in there still
nothing
do I have to do it like I didn't think I
had to put that but ya know I just
thought could say someone I got a weird
error here saying this thought get JSON
is not a function yeah I have it in
there don't I right oh shoot I need to
use an arrow function for this okay we
just went through this like last week so
already I'm forgetting so we need to use
an arrow function if you're not familiar
with arrow functions there are newer
thing
it's es2015 or sometimes called es6 in
this case the reason we want to use an
arrow function is because otherwise the
value of this is not what we want it to
be okay so we need this to mean like the
context of this basically this entire
component here right this is or at least
this section of the component so that's
why we did this so before when I clicked
it went through here but I got to this
point it said I don't know what get JSON
is okay because it was looking just
within this scope so that's why we use
the arrow function and you you actually
end up using arrow functions quite
frequently and react at least I I've
been having to use them frequently and
it's the same same concept here when
we're using this as well so I'm sure
there are other benefits using arrow
functions but for our purposes right now
that's the main benefit that's why we're
using it so I've saved that and let's
check it out
so we've got rid of the air that's a
good sign
oh yeah and it actually did it did what
we wanted so I'm going to refresh that
so we can see it happen okay
whoa I'll shoot because I'm calling it I
knew I didn't have to put that on there
anyway if you're wondering what I'm
talking to myself about here originally
I didn't call that there but then it
didn't work and I I thought hey it's not
working because I didn't do it right but
that's probably not what happened
so anyway it was just being invoked at
least I think let's test it out and see
if that's in fact what did happen okay
good so when I click this we should see
the switch yep
there we go awesome so we started with
events in June being here and going
further down into the timeline you know
further ahead in the future now we're
starting with the latest event and
working backwards so that works that
works like we wanted to do so so since
that works I'm going to go to the live
chat and just check out make sure I
haven't missed anything important and
then we'll see what time it is we were a
bit it's been like almost an hour to get
to this point so I'll see maybe we'll do
some more obviously we want it on a
second click we want to be able to sort
the other way as well so think about
that for a minute while I go through the
live chat I'm wondering if here's my
thought this is what I was thinking when
I first made this function what I'd
probably do is somehow just do like have
some variable it could even be a boolean
or something that gets checked to true
or false
when sort date is run and if it's true
it these params will change to either be
ascending or descending so I don't have
to write another function that does this
I just switch this function in or out so
it would accept
yeah I don't know somehow I would switch
that off that's what I'm thinking if you
have a better idea please let me know so
let's catch up here with the live chat
um Missouri has some some other
suggestions here for trying to get that
article to work that Andrew had linked
to so I'll have to have to check it out
alright I'm going to copy and paste
again this this new link that was sent
yeah that worked this time so cool
cool it looks good I'm scrolling through
this on my other screen here this looks
really cool I'm going to look through
this after the stream and see I'm always
I think I mentioned this before but I'm
a little bit restricted in terms of let
me bring this over like in terms of
layout like a lot of these decisions as
to how this worked like to make a change
really like required a meeting and
discussion so I'm so some changes are
probably fine and I can make it and it
wouldn't be a big deal but some changes
may require like more meetings like I
would make the change and then get an
email or phone call shortly thereafter
and so if the change is like for sure
like needs to be done would make it so
much better than I'm down to do that but
if it's not really going to be a huge
benefit to change it then it's probably
not worth it to go through all of that
so just so you know if you make a
suggestion even if it's awesome I might
not use it and it's not because I don't
think it's awesome it's just because of
that because of other factors so don't
don't feel that if your suggestion
doesn't make it in it's not it's not
exactly up to me what makes it in with
doesn't all right
it looks like I didn't really miss that
much in live chat I did a somewhat
decent job of keeping up with it
Patrick does mention the arrow function
lexically binds this to the parent scope
that's that's how you say it so hey
thanks Patrick so Patrick has given a
very accurate correctly worded
definition here for what I was trying to
say say with this so so I'll read that
again just because it was so good the
arrow function lexically binds this to
the parent scope so
all right Patrick says I feel like you
should be using state state for this so
do you mean is that in reference to me
saying something about I needed to go
both ways likes to switch the day and I
was talking about some sort of variable
that I would use like a boolean or
something if you're talking about that
let me know if you're talking about
something else haha Patrick says thanks
Scott Allen for that watch the video
about it yesterday so his is an arrow
function statement they're so cool I
mean I know like going through what was
it the book is that you don't know Jay s
is that the one that's on github and
this is totally free so I remember one
of those books or something I remember
getting the official definition at some
point but it's hard to remember okay so
all right so Jay stevemartina says sort
date is getting the data you should
already have in your state are you
meaning let me see
are you meaning that basically I already
have all this data in the state from
before so I don't need to make another
API call so let me know I think that's
what you mean
let me know if I'm wrong about that
Patrick says the fact that this table
can be sorted means it has multiple
states keep this stuff in state and let
react render the Dom based on it okay so
let's see okay and Jessie okay yeah says
does next yes when in production have an
index.html file I'll countered an issue
using next how do you deploy with the
index.html file um no I don't I don't
think there's an it so you would need to
deploy it to something that runs a node
so node can can run in index j s instead
of an index.html so that's what you need
so it may depend on where you're
deploying it to as to what what has to
happen
all right maybe if anybody in a live
chat has a better answer please PLEASE
add two to what I said but could you
explain maybe more about what your
production environment is like what are
you running in terms of the server and
then maybe maybe I gave you a better
answer okay so back to back to the whole
state thing help me out here so
basically this state
to saying keep this stuff in state and
let react render the dorm based on it
that's okay so Jonathan has just said
basically what I was kind of thinking
here
[Music]
can't we just sort the data so do this
data sort so yeah actually I've thought
about doing that I think I explained at
the beginning whether or not so I had
kind of two options either just sort the
data that I already have which will work
fine for now because we don't have that
many events or make a separate API call
the reason being when I make an API call
at some point when we get lots of events
I'm not going to grab every single event
with that first call so I'm not actually
going to have all the data saved in
state like right off the bat
so the idea what my thought process was
is would a user expect you know if they
if they hit this date here and let's say
we have 500 events and I've only loaded
100 events they're not necessarily going
to know that I've only loaded 100 events
if I'm only sorting the data I already
have then they're only getting you know
a small number you know with a try 500
then I get 100 they're only getting 1/5
of the possible events now the reason
I'm saying 100 is because in the
WordPress API there is a limit on how
many of the the post types you can grab
how many particular posts in that type
and the limit is 100 I'm assuming
there's some way around that I just
don't know it right now so I was based
on what I have right now that's was my
thinking for making a separate API call
so anybody have any insight on that you
know maybe I'm thinking too much about
this and it would be fine to just sort
what I have but I expected some point
that there will be quite a few events
here I don't really know what to expect
exactly I'm not I'm not getting this
data and I'm not entering this data in
so I'm just not I'm not sure maybe maybe
it'll never be that many events but I'd
like to be prepared for that
okay so Jonathan Jonathan said that
makes sense okay all right good yeah I
kind of like my first thought was
simpler and it seemed a lot easier like
I'll just sort all the data that I
already have and potentially that would
just be that would be faster anyway it
already happens pretty fast so I'm not
worried that much about speed but all
right so that's why I'm making another
API call it's not going to be that easy
I think with everything as the date the
dates the easiest thing to sort on but
that's the basic idea so I think before
I end this video I wanted to keep the
videos short like around an hour so
since there's not a lot of questions I
think I'm going to finish up with at
least this portion so that we can suit
when we click on it again it takes us
back to the initial state so I'd like to
finish that because I think that would
give if anybody else wants to like watch
this and implement something similar if
we finish at least that one that would
give enough info I think to repeat it
with multiple rows so let's try to
finish this up and then I'll end the
video normally I do you know kind of
like I'm actually pretty long Q&A
session at the end but there's just not
a lot of questions so we won't have to
have to do that
so Patrick says okay well you want to
conditionally sort based on the current
state of the table you need to store
that in state also don't retrieve the
data over and over if the user clicks
date again okay thank you for the
explanation that makes perfect sense so
Patrick's point here is so I had
initially when it loaded I had all the
data from this API call saved in state
and then
i overrode all that with everything in
this API code now when I want to click
that again I'm basically going to make
this API call again which doesn't make
any sense why not if I've gotten the
state at once when I keep it stored so
that does make sense and Patrick let me
know if that is in fact what you meant I
think it is but if not let me know so
the thing is it's not enough for us just
to keep making these API calls again and
again because that's a waste although we
will be caching API calls so technically
it won't it won't necessarily require
like a search through the database on
the WordPress end but still it does make
sense it'd be better to just keep it in
state so let me think
I'm just thinking about how how I'm
going to do this so that I can keep
things in state and here's what I'm
thinking let me know if this makes sense
or if you have a better idea so
basically I'm still going to do this at
the beginning this is going to be saved
to data right in in-state then when you
click to sort before this gets soared to
data I'm going to basically take what's
currently stored in data and I'm going
to store it in some other variables so I
don't even know maybe I'll call it old
data right now I don't know there's
going to be a better name probably but
that of any name will work so basically
everything that wasn't data now gets
stored in old data and so it we still
keep it all and then at the point when I
want to switch back I just take what's
in I can take what's in old data and
move it flip it back up to data and this
switch switch them out basically so I
keep both of them now it it becomes more
complicated when I add this to the other
rows and do I want to keep every call so
I may have to yeah it's I certainly
could keep every call and just make
different you know different sections
within the state you know to hold them
all does that make sense
okay so Bastian says save the sorted
data in sorted data
when I got some other I got some
detailed advice here so let me read
through this Patrick says so grab
ascending once grab descending once and
then render based on state all right
awesome so it looks like I did get that
right so Alberto says for name if you're
pretty sure that the last name will
always be last you could do sort by like
current valid split and okay so you say
I can split it I'm actually not certain
that the less I'm not certain of
anything concerning the name I could
probably like suggest a naming
convention and have it right there and
the instructions for whoever's importing
it in so assuming that they follow the
instructions maybe I could have some
certainty that that would be it
so maybe all right so let's let's get to
this let's take a crack at this saving
stuff in state and I'm going to I'm
actually pretty excited about this
because I mean this kind of gets at
least for me this kind of gets to the
thing that's cool about react is you
know changing of state and having things
rerender on the page very quickly right
that's that's what's awesome about react
among other things so being able to
manipulate things like this is what I'd
like to be able to do better than I'm
already doing it so because I need to
move out of building things like this in
jQuery to building things like this in
react which is much preferable to the
the mess that usually happens when I try
to build this out in jQuery which which
starts out very simple and nice and then
as features get added it just becomes
very hard to maintain so let's just this
is kind of try out um
let's say so now I am going to use just
the the silly name of old data no that's
not what I want I want to set the state
so this set state and I want to use let
me use I guess I can just call I will
call it old data so stop me if I'm doing
this wrong but I'm going to use old data
now I'm just going to use data right
that's what needs to happen and then now
this gets set so that'll be safe so
that's the first step and I've just
saved it and I've got no error messages
I have it up on my other screen so
that's good sign
um now we need a way to switch it back
so how am I going to do this
let's see if I could just do
I'm blanking out here so hey so I'm
actually don't forget to set up the
default state oh okay
Sebastian says why not make both API
calls on page load and then save them to
state then make the button just change
what is displayed pulled from the state
that's a great idea however at least I
probably could do it on component amount
so I couldn't I can't make another API
call here at least I don't I've tried
before and it's come up with errors so
there's I assume there's some way to
make multiple calls here so it's not
going to be here but what I could do is
on component did mount I could do it
then
would that be preferable ought I to make
all the API calls that I need on page
load or should I wait because a user may
not ever even click to need that would
it just be what do you all think would
that be would that be preferable because
if a user did use it it would be faster
or would it be more of a waste of
bandwidth because I'd be making lots of
unnecessary API calls I'm not I don't I
don't really have a decision one way or
the other at this point
I'm going to think about it so let me
know okay so Patrick saying set up the
default state do you mean like here I
need to set like old data up here and
then have it do this I'm assuming that
what you meant okay so this that state
old data equals data so we've got that
oh no I know that's what I need to do I
should have wrote in some comments what
was going to happen so I wouldn't forget
so I usually do but so basically here we
need to have a check what the current
stay is and change data
okay so basically I need to figure out
which way it's sorted ascending or
descending and then change the data so I
need to flip this data around one way or
another but I need to know I need some
some way so what did I say earlier I was
just going to have some some check like
so we can make it
actually what if we had here this is my
idea what if we also added so let's say
for each row so so basically we have we
have data that's always going to be what
gets rendered there is whatever is in
data but then for each row we not only
have you know old data and then I'm
going to change it so this will end up
being like date ascending date
descending we'll probably have that so
let's just do that now since that's what
was going to be date ascending and then
date descending and but then also we're
going to have a date current state does
that make sense
is that too much because this I get
ended up being like repeated for several
of the rows but my thought is eventually
we could have the ascending and
descending both save to these and then
the this will just basically say whether
or not it's ascending or descending and
that doesn't have to be a value that
could end up being I just a true or
false right so
I mean this it could maybe be something
like is date ascending true or false
right I don't know this seems more
descriptive me what it's actually doing
though let me know what you all think I
don't need that okay so what what it
will do then is
check so too many commas in class
I think he's Jonathan just said too many
comments I think he was referring to
this last comment that I just took out
so
[Music]
sorry I'm kind of like really slow it's
actually super hot here and I'm
literally just like sweating and
sweating I don't want to turn my fan on
because it's going to mess up the sound
for the video but I'm like dressed up in
a dress clothes and everything for my
job and I'm just like dying here
so actually I'm gonna I'm gonna need
some water hold on a second I just I
don't have to go anywhere I'm just gonna
kind of pour it right here okay all
right cool Jonathan Jonathan said you
got that's what I that's what I thought
it's tough cuz there's a delay when
we're when we're doing this so I think
you know sometimes there is like a
little mix-up of of things Sebastian
said is 31.5 degree C in his room which
I'm in the United States so I don't
really know how hot that is anybody know
what that is in Fahrenheit I could look
it up real quick
all right so that is really hot that's
like almost 90 degrees Fahrenheit for
those of you in the u.s. so I actually
used Celsius and the metric system when
I'm cooking
but then for the temperature I use
Fahrenheit and that's I don't think
that's common to use it for cooking in
the u.s. people still six in Fahrenheit
but all the cooking shows that I like
are all usually from from the UK and so
they they use Celsius so anyway let's
get back to this so Sebastian if he
feels my pain right now because it's
also super hot where he is um okay so I
still need some way so I have these set
up at least a place to store what I want
to store but I still need some way to
set that and then and then check it so
actually the initial state is always
going to be ascending right because
that's what we're loading first so the
initial state for that will be ascending
so I guess I could just put I could just
put it in there
I mean authoritah just put it right
there okay we said about stuff in the
live chat I'm going to check Flint
Frankie I'm not sure how to pronounce
Fla n ck e says old data could be an
object that holds the query parameter
used to get the data from the API so you
can specify what old data exactly holds
and you don't have to do the same API
request again
okay so it could hold the query it could
actually hold the params okay
I'm just so I'm just checking out the
the code that was just put in live chat
just to see see what's going on there
okay
wondering
actually all right I just had an idea
sorry if this is annoying you I keep
having ideas and changing things but if
this if this what makes sense this might
actually work better than whatever I was
trying to do right here so I have set it
up before and I have it set up basically
I've set up caching of the API calls
like when I did something like this but
I did it with all jQuery stuff I set up
caching of the API calls so that
obviously I wouldn't have to make more
requests and it was set up so that every
time an API call was made so basically
this portion had a check inside of here
and so it checked to see if those query
params had already been saved and the
reason I thought about this is is
because Frankie just had the suggestion
of saving the actual params along with
the data so that got me thinking like
well why not do that and so basically
the it would be key we could essentially
have key value pairs stored up and the
key would be the query parameter in fact
the entire URL would be the key and then
the value would be the data so that each
time I go to make the API request it
checks to see if it's already been made
and if it has been made instead of
return making the API call it just
returns what was saved and the key value
pairs it could be saved
I think it when I did it before I
actually saved it in in local storage
and I gave it an expiration as well so
there was there's another piece of data
there too but I don't know does that
make sense does that make more sense
than the lamb doing it right now - kind
of like basically simplify things so
that I don't have to spell all this out
beforehand and it just kind of would
build everything up and store it I don't
know let me know
I'm just wondering anyway so what I just
described I'm just wondering like would
that be the react way to do things like
I said before I used local storage to do
that but is that not the react way to do
it what are the REC way to do it in fact
be to just have it all set in state and
and do it like that and not have not hit
[Music]
local storage not save stuff in there at
this point I think I'm kind of
overthinking it I knew that's why if you
read the the tweet that I put out for
this video I said I'm attempting to do
this I wasn't sure that I would actually
get it done
all right so I'm not getting any
response back it may be a little bit of
a delay so I'm not getting response back
on that so
and I'm also losing viewers so I suspect
that some people are in agreement with
me that I'm overthinking this and it's
taking too long
click once
actually let me do a let me do a silly
thing let
you
toggle can I use that let's take table
will equal zero state toggle
those flus
if
if you're watching this and you're
thinking what am i doing then I'm kind
of thinking that too so just wait the
idea the idea is this this is actually
going to be really simple why not just
set this variable oops I need to set
this actually somewhere else outside of
here so let's say let's actually make
date current state equal to
[Music]
hmm
can I just said something in state I
don't have to make it equal to an array
right could I just potentially make this
equal to zero and then current state
this let's see this doc current state
I don't think so worry I've never tried
this before this said state hold data
let's go with
start state
you stay
and I think my editor for us it's not
let me do it there we go all right
awesome that's what I thought Patrick
just confirmed that I can set properties
however I want um where am I at
okay so the idea is basically like I'm
just going to be able to click on this a
bunch of time so instead of I don't know
an easy way it might be like let's just
increment every time I click it and then
if it's an odd number
it's the ascending if it's an even
number is descending some makes sense
everybody and then that way it'll just
keep track so what I need to do then I'm
setting it initially to zero okay so the
first time it runs alright it'll just be
one and then we're going to do an if
statement here it's going to say so we
need to make a call at some point so
let's do
alright so the first time it definitely
does it does have to make the call
because we have to get the data
so I guess would be slightly more
complicated than I expected
alright Umberto's says I always use bull
and set the value to exclamation point
value so I used to not buy okay um let
me does this make sense out doing it or
is this just silly and more complicated
than it needs to be be honest with me
because honestly I'm this is taking a
lot longer than I expected it to and I
kind of want to just either finish this
tomorrow or like get it working as fast
as possible and then fix it up tomorrow
or something I'd hate to just end the
video at this point because it would
feel slightly like a failure even though
we kind of did what we wanted to do okay
Patrick says it does make sense but it's
a bit harder to understand me you come
back to it okay I do I do agree yeah I
think it would just be better if I could
just have one value or another here's
what I'm thinking though I'm just
blanking here on maybe I should try
streaming in the morning and my brain
would be better at times I just maybe
it's the fact that I am streaming and I
so I'm trying to think and talk but
occasionally it just seems like I'm
better able to figure out this sort of
thing when I'm not streaming I like to
do it with all of you because you give
me great ideas too but in terms of my
contribution to this it always seems
harder when I'm doing it but anyway what
I what I basically have stuck at is when
I click how do I change how do I change
whatever value I'm going to put here
whether it be a boolean or what and then
check that check that here like I know
what needs to happen but the step in
between I'm just drawing a blank on what
the best way to do that is
okay umberto has an idea
so and we also so Frankie says if so if
WordPress returns only the first 500
resources is there a flag that says if
there are more in this case if we know
all resources are returned then we can
just sort it on the front end okay
it actually WordPress only returns 100
resources but regardless the point is
still valid I don't think there's a flag
that returns ID I'll have to check the
documentation to see if there's it may
have to be a separate API call but the
API call I might be able to just get the
number of how many I'm dealing with so
yeah but it there's no flag I mean this
basically this is the data that gets
returned and that's all this it's just
this repeated over again I am cutting
out some of the fields so there probably
would be some sort of ID let me see if
there's an ID field okay so there is an
ID but it looks like that's not going to
help me I was thinking that it would
start it like one and keep going up but
it looks like it it doesn't because this
is registering 260 and there's no way I
have 260 so that won't help let me just
take all of this out right now and see
let's get everything and see if there's
something I've never seen anything that
I know of but I've never looked either
no all right looks like there's nothing
there that would tell me so anyway so I
mean that was a good thought I wish it
did work out like that I know it's
possible to edit the API within
WordPress to make it do other things
that it doesn't do but I don't I'm not
as confident with my PHP skills as I
would need to be I think to make that
happen
Nuno says hi really nice really nice
lives good work Thanks
thanks for watching all right so Patrick
says how about
date is ascending true and that's
default date is ascending equals not
data sasanian okay all right so let's
see so basically let's see so let's
change
I do like I'm gonna go with date is
ascending since that is state is sending
equals true that's the first one so now
when we get in here we toggle so date is
ascending equals date is okay so now
this is going to toggle and then within
here we're going to do one or the other
but I still I still do have one issue
and that's basically I don't want to
make this call every single time what I
could do is set up that cache like I was
talking about earlier so it doesn't
matter I can't make this call every time
and it's not actually going to to call
anything if it's cash because I'll cash
it up and here somewhere
or otherwise I need a way for within
here for this only one run once or
potentially I guess I could have this
check as well to say if oh yeah I can
just check the state right I can just
check and see if there's any data in
descending then I'm not going to make
that call right yeah that makes sense
and that won't require me setting up a
separate cache which might be
complicated so
this data oops now if this state and I
figure what I call it date descending
date descending I could probably just
check the length right like Shelley ng
th length is greater than zero right
length is greater than zero then we're
going to do all this stuff right
otherwise and not only so this will
actually be wrapped nested if statements
this should be read if um date
so you want this to be with if it is
ascending if they is ascending so I mean
if that is true then we want to do this
and actually let's if this is else 20
tails after I fixed after I do this then
let me know if there's a way I could
refactor this to make it better but just
to get this done I'm doing it like doing
it kind of a very basic way I guess so
basically we went to this thought data
our dates
folks this state sorry
okay this state date descending right
yeah
date descending is going to equal whoops
now that ah why am i my brain just not
working here so I need this set state
and now I need to set date descending no
I don't wait if the state if state
length I need to say set data that's it
that's what I'm going he said data to
date descending okay so is ascending let
me make sure that this has happened so
if the date is ascending and date
descending length is greater than nice
that's flipped around if it's it needs
to be I would say not equal to zero
because that's going to return zero
right it should right
[Music]
yeah you guys should have looked just
like Jonathan Jonathan caught that
before I did so good good look on that
one I'm going to check the other posts
here in the live chat just to see if
anyone caught anything else that I
messed up on
okay so Frankie says from the WordPress
API page to determine how many pages of
data are available the API returns two
header fields so xwp total the total
number of records in the collection okay
very nice thank you for that information
I'm not going to do anything with it
right now obviously because this video
has been too long as it is but I'm gonna
look that up either probably not today
I'll probably leave as soon as I'm done
with this but tomorrow if I get a chance
I will look that up as well thank you
all right so States to know for your
data and get rid of the length check all
to get all together
Patrick's saying set initial states to
null for your data and get rid of the
length check all together okay I will
that sounds good I will ask though
initially for at least for this data we
set this here so that we wouldn't get an
error potentially down below but since
we're not directly calling any of these
down below then it shouldn't be an issue
correct and I'll wait a minute before I
change that to see hopefully or if you
need more explanation for that but I
think some of you were around for when
we kind of when we talked did this part
on our on our resources and why we set
it like that in the first place
Umberto's says I'm kind of confused
you're checking if we are currently
trying to sort by date ascending you
want to check if we have data for date
descending
mint data sending and date descending
okay yeah that's what I thought so it
shouldn't make a difference then right
alright so so basically Patrick just to
give this right so I could do something
like should I legit like just putting
all there or can I just leave this blank
let me know
so then down here I could just say get
rid of the length and is this says stay
equals equals null so is this what you
were thinking something like this or let
me know so anyway that would work if
it's an all them we need to fill it with
something otherwise we need to set data
to the date descending because otherwise
that means we actually already have set
this at some point and so we need to set
it back so if date is ascending if date
is already descending right so if it's
this one so that would be the else for
this right else we've obviously already
we've already switched it over so all we
need to do is something like this right
data ascending so at that point we've
already we don't have to switch any data
around because the first time that this
would have been clicked it would have
saved this we need to change this and
set this to data ascending right okay so
first time it's click date ascending
gets set so we never have to set it
again right
also first time this is click this gets
set to data so but we also want
we also actually want this set here so
probably this would be the place where
we could set the date descending set
data to date descending or I'm sorry
take set date descending to data right
yeah so whatever there
oh there
all right let's try I think I'm at the
point where I could actually try this
and I'm sure if there's some error you
all have seen it and oh you let me know
oops
oh good look okay so Patrick had a
wonderful idea
um like obviously I don't need to call
set state twice so I can just do
descending can I do it like so could i
potentially do
so I could do it like that I mean I'm
assuming it this we both happen in order
as well so it would be fine and I'm
assuming that's what you were referring
to Patrick okay and I fixed that all
right so let's see I was getting an
error
I'll bring the service you can see why
am I get an error
let me i'm just restarting the dev
server because occasionally that causes
problems okay cool so Patrick is
verified then that that that is what
what he was referring to what we just
changed
all right great we got a page load
always a good sign and let's go down
here so everything loaded up so we
haven't broken that and now here's going
to be the first click uh and nothing
happened on the first click all right so
let's see let me just see if we're
actually if we are going to get any
errors here there's my console I'll
bring the console over so we can all see
the errors so here's what we're getting
oh let's go to the top here ok I'll call
it reference their date is ascending is
not defined yep now I understand what is
going on here so it's going to be this
dot date is ascending right that's why I
couldn't find it am i using where else
am i using that this dot date is
ascending is equal to how would I so
what I need to could I just do it like
that or should I actually write in
something else all right so anyway
hopefully this works
I just want to check and make sure I'm
not using this anywhere else if I
highlighted it should show me yep this
there we go
and let me make sure I'm not oops and it
needs to be state 2 there we go this
state just a date ascending okay I think
that's everywhere that I'm referencing
something in state then I need to change
so
okay here's the next era I'm getting
it's saying data is not defined on line
59 let's check it out
oh no no obviously that's not it
where am I not defined where's data not
define
yes we do
all right where I'll show this I'll show
this to you again because obviously I
have I'm using data a lot so trying to
figure out why it's saying it's not
defined let me check the latch at sea
Mauro's thought that this state data is
a sending thing before I did so thank
you I I didn't look over and see that
you caught that but thanks thanks for
catching that pastor Gong sook let's say
everybody caught it except for me and I
just didn't look over in time to see it
oh okay I see what Patrick is saying so
basically let me what's happening here
is the default state is ascending right
but then here I'm setting the state I'll
take this out because I'm not actually
doing it here what I'm doing is I'm
setting the state to say that it's not
ascending and then I'm checking this so
obviously it's checking to see if this
is ascending and it's saying no it's not
ascending so set it to ascending so
that's why I'm not seeing anything
happen so Patrick rightly says put this
at the bottom
okay and I I didn't do anything about
that error that says date is not defined
so I expect to get that again
I suppose alright so here's the air that
I'm getting data is not defined now it's
saying it's at line 52 this at state
data why are we getting
okay so data should be maybe it's a
problem with the API call I'm going to
check real quick to make sure that this
actually works
okay so you alright that it does
actually work so when I put this in the
browser it is returning data so we
should be getting data back and
let's see in that case the data you're
referencing should be this state data
also you need to use set state for the
toggle oh okay yeah good alright so I
guess I got some input about these
errors here so it should be data date
descending not dates and data so ever
yet this says state where we add
Oh
you're right
well you actually
so Frankie is saying it should be data :
date descending not the other way around
which which line are you talking about
as you said also you need to set state
okay so I do need to set state for the
toggle so this state date is descending
so and I do need it for the table I need
assess a so I need this dot set state
and we're gonna go date is ascending and
I should be able to just to do this
start set state oops this dot state dot
date is ascending no yes wait a second
this state Davis ascending equals
oh I see
I see I've messed this up a bit
all right mrs. 948 I have
data ascending instead of Davison in
life 48
okay so so I have like two different
issues that I'm both getting feedback on
in the live chat so I apologize for
those watching the recording of this
because you can't see the live chat
because there's a lot going on in there
so in regard to the error of the the
data okay then we're saying data is at
at this point not local to this function
so it needs to be this state data which
makes sense that's why I saying data is
not defined in this case it's okay
because we're getting the data from this
this call so it'll be okay and then
where else am I using data so down here
I also need to use it state uh
autocomplete for me okay this state data
there okay great so that um should fix
that error I'm just going to check that
real quick so I'm going to ignore this
for just a second just to make sure I'm
not getting that same error
oops I got a different error so that's
good I didn't get the same error and
okay shoot yeah this this threw an error
really quick so let me let me just take
this out just for a second I just want
to make sure to take this one at a time
I want to make sure that I fix the data
error thing
and it looks like I'm not getting that
error but I'm still not getting the
result that I want so okay yeah so until
you fix the error okay okay it looks
like I have a typo as well Matt says
there's a typo in the left half of :
declaration the second a should be an e
all right let me let me try to find that
um this state data what am I looking at
I don't see it was it in here
I'm trying to find the the taper but I'm
not finding it
okay so Patrick says you're moving
things around in state as if it is a
cash you need to make sure that when
you're removing something in state you
reference it with this state data okay
oh yes thank you
uh I need I need curly brackets okay
that obviously is an issue let's see my
rumps is a yes inline 48 I'm at 48 this
said state date ascending there we go
thank you I I looked in this area
several times I just couldn't see it
thank you very much
thanks Matt agon and Patrick for
everybody responded with the line so
everybody can see that except for me
okay so I think we're really close to
this the only part that I'm not sure on
so Patrick in particular but anybody can
can contribute here so I know I edited
this a little bit from what it was
originally have I messed this line up
line 56 do I need to change this it was
originally it was originally different
than this correct Patrick says it's much
easier to catch mistakes when you're
just watching deleted okay good
thanks Patrick so Patrick says I can act
I can delete this line see so this set
state data is ascending this
and then add to set state
Patrick says I need to add an
exclamation point to the set state do I
add it I'll just get at in here let me
know if that's not the right place to
add it in here oh there's a nut Morrow
sees 156 before this state okay life
before this state declarations okay good
so that is in fact yep
all right awesome okay I saved that and
let me bring bring this over
if I get any errors as well I'll bring
the the console over and let's try it
out what is going on
oops wrong page all right um all right
let me refresh that
okay so that's what it should be and we
click it great now let's click it again
okay when we click it again we get an
error well at least it works at least
you didn't get crazy errors at first
right off the bat so data setting is not
defined and events J s56 let's check it
out fifty-six all right that's what we
were just talking about so date is oh my
hat day descending he's not defined
in line 56 I'm not even using that am I
in line 56 this sad state date is
ascending this to state day please okay
listen
that's an odd error right am I am I
missing something obviously I'm not even
using this online 56 but I am using it
this state Davis oh do I need to do this
data equals this state that's probably
it all right now let's bring this over
we refresh okay alright so click changes
changes nice ok it worked in case you
didn't catch that it did work we clicked
once we click twice and the first two
clicked work the third click he'll ever
gives us an error here date descending
is not defined which this at this point
this is easy because I feel like I've
had keep having the same error instead
of just yep this state date descending
okay and that makes sense because this
wouldn't actually have fired until the
third click anyway so good so this
should be this was the only line that
hadn't fired yet so assuming we fix this
which I think we did this should work so
I'm gonna I'm just going to make sure I
refresh to reset the state back to the
original state and it figures the dev
server would just hang so all right I
feel it I feel like we're close I said
at the beginning that this is going to
be one of those times when I don't
really know what I'm doing or how I'm
going to do it but I'm going to learn a
lot and I feel really good when it
happens I think this is about to happen
alright so click one works
click to works here's click 3 it works
yay we go back and forth and just to
show the network let's see if we can
find I'll show you the network so here
is where we actually got our descending
things so you can see it's only fired
once we just click like I don't know six
seven times it only fired once so we did
only fetch the data one time and it
never fires again after that so awesome
great job everybody for sure
yay on this one this was a little bit me
and mostly all of you helping out so I
pretty much just brought the here's what
we need to do and then you all brought
most of the most of the other stuff I
really appreciate that this has been Wow
over two hours of a video I did so well
the other like yesterday it was like an
hour you know so I was doing good and
then then we went we went over so we
went way over the normal time hey thanks
everybody some Christian said congrats
but thanks for the congrats but really
like congratulations to all of you for
for kind of coaching me through all that
I'm sure it was frustrating at some
times when it actually cooled down in my
office and my brains a little bit more
clearer now but there were there was a
time there in kind of the middle that my
brain was just not working and you all
kind of had to had to hold my hand there
and say baby steps with me so yeah I
appreciate that a voice Allah says we
hope we see you soon so yeah but Co soon
so thank you very much for all the help
and hopefully this helps somebody
watching to know how to do this
obviously you could you know repeat
these steps now I will say this this in
particular we're using the WordPress API
right so I'm basically
going the the sorting through the
wordpress api if you wanted to do this
and you like already had the data and
you didn't want to make another API call
then you'd have to do the sorting on the
data you already had if we had done it
that way I think it would have been
helpful to more people but obviously as
we discussed earlier in this case at
least at this point since I can only get
a hundred entries per page for the
events I needed to keep making API calls
because I think that otherwise the user
would not be seeing everything you know
all of the events available so just so
that's that's clear that there's a
different way to do it to actually sort
on the data maybe I'll have an
opportunity to do something like that if
I can figure out how to get all the
entries or something because I would
like to do that as well because I think
it would be helpful for you all and
certainly there'll be occasion for me to
use in the future
but other than that little caveat
hopefully this is some stuff that you
can use in your projects and this was
certainly helpful for me so I'll be back
tomorrow at 2:00 and I'm thinking Friday
I might not do a stream so I was I was
gonna do a stream earlier in the day but
I now have a meeting so I don't think
I'll be able to do it early I'm going on
vacation next week but I'm leaving
Friday nights and I'm going to drive
through the night so it takes about
eight hours to get where I'm going to
the beach and I'm driving my family
through the night so the kids can all
sleep and I think I probably should
leave work early and take a nap
so that I can safely drive throughout
the night
so it'd be probably best if I left work
a little bit early so I don't think I'll
be able to do a stream if something
changes I'll certainly let you know but
as of right now I don't think a stream
will be possible for me on Friday I
really wanted to do
since I may not be able to do one for
all week but really I really do want to
make sure that I'm awake enough to drive
safely you know through the whole night
so I do plan on hopefully making some
recorded videos and maybe releasing them
next week so hopefully you'll have that
so you may not have any live streams but
I'll be releasing recorded videos and
those will go on my youtube channel free
code camp is just for the live streams
and then my like recorded videos will be
on my channel so anyway so enough talk
for me you're awesome that you stuck
around this long and I know some of you
in different time zones it's like two
o'clock in the morning now so so go to
sleep and and I'll see y'all tomorrow
and thanks again